I just remember it was so captivating
really kind of alien like this
strange-looking material is not
computer-generated what you're seeing is
a liquid with nano sized particles of
iron in it reacting to a magnetic field
it's called ferrofluid it was first
developed by NASA an artist Eric misplay
has been using it in his work for the
past 12 years every single sculpture I
feel like I tackle with very fluid I
have no idea how I'm gonna get this to
work when I go in Eric is a master metal
worker and builder he built this giant
top and a literal metal jacket my father
when I was 11 years old he got me an
anvil and I started blacksmithing when I
was younger I would make all sorts of
stuff from gates ornamental spoons and
swords but ever since coming across
ferrofluids in a scientific article as a
graduate student
he's been captivated by it the more I
read about it
and the characteristics of it I just the
whole time was thinking man I really
want to do something with this stuff and
when you were a kid you could see the
magnetic field in a 2d iron filings on a
piece of paper you could see that
striations of it but now you're actually
seeing with all these notes coming off
of it what the magnetic field looks like
in a three dimensional realm
nasa-developed ferrofluids in the early
1960s engineer Steve papel was trying to
figure out how to draw rocket fuel into
the engine in zero gravity
his solution he would magnetize it
now the magnetic fuel was never actually
adopted for spaceflight but ferrofluids
are used in a number of different
commercial applications and even to
create an airtight seal around your
computer's hard drive it's been used for
many different things but what I use it
for is none of those things I use it to
show off how beautiful it looks
what you're seeing is Eric increasing
the power to the electromagnet until
eventually the fluid jumps and it forms
into those little cones because that's
the magnetic field but also you know
that's least resistance to when
something gets skinnier and skinnier and
then it you know goes right up towards
the magnet itself the very first time I
got fair fluid I had it shipped from a
company called Ferro tech and they're
the ones that make ferrofluid I noticed
instantly that it was totally totally
messy I mean it's like black ink so you
know I had ink all over myself but I
would were just natural magnets and and
you know move it around and just stare
at it and go wow this is crazy
but even the characteristics of me
playing with it with the magnet it was
different than what I thought it wasn't
quite moving how I wanted it to move or
I envisioned it moving but it was
nonetheless still intriguing and
beautiful to me I decided to do my first
project which was the Machine effect in
effect I made a very large sphere there
was a huge natural magnet inside the
sphere teaching himself how to code Erik
program the movement of the magnet so it
would seemingly become attracted to a
viewer who approached the sphere I think
there's something really important about
connecting people with a piece of work
not only just visually but what you're
doing is affecting it for his next
project Erik built a wall of ferrofluid
that would mirror the shape of the
viewer standing in front of it
I was originally thinking of you know
that pin toy where you would like push
her hand in and all the pins would come
out and make a shape of your hand I
really wanted to do a version of that
that was with just this fluid and as you
would walk in front it would make a very
you know 8-bit kind of representation of
you in real time I made 320
electromagnets and I placed it behind
this wall and I had a pump that would
recirculate the fluid up to the top and
run over the surface of it I had to
build all of the computer chips computer
components right the program I built
every single magnet you know every
single problem I ran into I kind of had
to figure out how to solve it Eric
quickly ran into issues with the pumps
that circulated the ferrofluid these
cheap pumps that you buy habit of a
magnet they kind of spin around and
that's what turns it all this fluid it's
just dragging around on the pump system
so it was adding tons of resistance in
every half hour two hours I was blowing
them out I finally decided I'm just
gonna tip the whole thing over and make
it into a pool and so that was my third
piece that one's called Fair flexion
pool I was in a class and it was an
interactive musical class and there was
a professor there who specialized in
what's called max/msp and it's a way of
programming for a lot of stuff in the
music industry and lighting and things
timed an image is captured from an old
xbox the computer program tells this
microcontroller right here in the center
and then this microcontroller tells
these driver boards which magnets to
turn on or off and it just makes a real
pixelated simple representation of what
it's picking up through the camera
the whole time in the class everyone
else is working on their music projects
I am trying to build a program for the
sculpture I want tons of wires tons of
connections tons of problems left and
right and eventually it got working as
Eric built on his experience with
ferrofluids he had to learn more and
more about magnetism and how to build
his own electromagnets in science class
your professor would take a nail and
then he would wrap the nail with copper
wire and then it connected to a battery
and then you could pick up you know
little paperclips or whatever that's
what I was going for using the same
concept
Eric built larger and more powerful
electromagnets to make the fluid jump
further well when I first turned it on
we weren't sure if it was working so I
kind of waved a crescent wrench over it
and and it immediately just sucked it
out of my hand and stuck right to the
magnet as he built stronger magnets he
faced new challenges he is a huge factor
with magnets so if a magnet gets too hot
it gets saturated and meaning the
magnetic field isn't really that optimal
for how much current you're really
putting into it
Eric developed a coolant system for
these larger more powerful magnets so
this is the next electromagnet this is
the bottom part of the coolant system so
this place is in here and another
version of this coolant system goes down
here on the steel so it's being cooled
from both sides as well as through the
center in his 2016 peace killing time
eric says he built his strongest
electromagnet yet I'm guessing that that
magnet attached properly could probably
pick up like a thousand pounds maybe his
small car
[Music]
my father you know he was very much of a
builder as well as being an artist so I
was helping out my father like
physically built stuff when I was a very
young kid he introduced me to the
foundries Loveland Colorado have some of
the biggest founders in the nation
surprisingly but started with mold
making and wax chasing and then I'm
moved up to pouring molten metal and to
welding and then eventually lead welder
most of the other lead welders were you
know in their young 40s I just enjoyed
creating I thought it was really awesome
to just build things with my hand and
watch something unfold and be complete
my dad's done tons of huge drawings I
still remember one drawing he had done
this thing was massive him as you know
like 9 feet by 14 feet and just the way
he would draw I was really blown away
with if you do like a section over here
and then he'd do a section over here and
then a section over here and then the
whole thing would like completely come
together absolutely perfect and he
didn't really outline the the piece as a
whole if just the whole thing would just
fit together all of a sudden I was
around this all the time I was around
you know this sense of wonderment
because my dad was doing things that no
one else was doing I think overall the
goal has been to you know create a sense
of art that kind of reefs to meu lates
people about art
a lot of sculptures I try to make I try
to show like the what ifs or how is this
possible to even do something like this
those are the fun questions for me to
try to showcase in this type of work the
unforeseen thing that's what most people
don't realize is I have failed so many
times trying to figure this stuff out
but as time goes on I figure more and
more and more out and I don't know if a
lot of people stick with something that
is that frustrating for a long time my
current project I'm using light and and
and trying to bend the light with the
magnet what's happening is is as the
magnet is spinning the microscopic
particles of the iron they're actually
moving in the plane of glass so when you
see the light look like it's moving it's
actually the way the iron particles are
moving and the light is refracting off
of them adding the light on this new
system is it as a whole new starting
point of frustrations for me
frustrations are just part of working
with is mesmerizing material
[Music]
it's so hard to even master anything in
life with this fluid I feel like it's
this is just the beginning and now I've
been into it for 10 to 12 years now so
there's a lot left
[Music]